23rd of June 2016. a date that will go
down in history on that day 51.9 of
British people voted to leave the
European Union the divorce had been
confirmed brexit would become a reality
which of course is exactly what happened
but do you remember what the main
Promises of the pro-brexit campaign were
well there were many but this was by far
one of the most important and decisive I
am making one very simple point
we cannot have any form of managed
migration into Britain and remain a
member of the European Union because we
have an open door to nearly half a
billion people brexit is only way to
control immigration campaigners claim in
fact as you can see polls prior to the
referendum clearly showed that the vast
majority of britons whether they were
brexit supporters or not believed that
brexit would allow the British
government to take back control of the
borders and thus reduce the huge number
of immigrants that were entering the
country brexit entailed many things but
electorally speaking it mainly involved
controlling immigration and the effects
that would have on the health system
schools the labor market and the daily
lives of the British people well since
then no less than seven long years have
passed and the question we can ask is
what exactly has brexit meant for
immigration has it really delivered on
This Promise Well visualpolitik
Community the data seems to say
something very different 24 November
2022 UK immigration nearly triples
despite brexit promises each July 2023
Channel migrant Crossings hit new daily
record for 2023. the immigration debate
has become one of the central issues at
10 Downing Street
despite the fact that the United Kingdom
can now manage its borders again the
arrival of immigrants has not only
decreased but has actually increased and
this despite the fact that the economic
situation in the country is not
particularly good so the question we
were wondering is to what extent has the
UK become a country open to immigration
what has happened to what was one of the
great Promises of brexit did you know
that sunak's team hopes to make
immigration or rather the fight against
immigration its big political bet in the
run-up to the next elections in 2025
well in this video we're going to learn
all of the details about the huge wave
of immigration that the UK is
experiencing so let's get started
open the gates
visualpolitik Community it is impossible
to talk about the UK post-brexit without
mentioning Alexander Boris de fiefel
Johnson you know Bojo Boris Johnson yeah
that guy the same guy who was able to
offer tea to journalists in the morning
struggle with an umbrella in the middle
of the day and placate children during
rugby matches in the afternoon that has
got to be one of my favorite Clips in
short one of the most colorful and
controversial characters in modern
politics Britain Trump a politician who
was one of the great Advocates and
promoters of brexit in fact he was
probably the most senior conservative
leader to Advocate this position and yes
among the reasons Johnson also talked
about immigration and border control
take a look for me this is a question of
democracy it's about public consent and
explaining to people and the moment we
have absolutely no power to control our
immigration what's more Johnson insisted
again and again that remaining part of
the European Union meant giving up any
control over the Border it is deeply
corrosive to popular confidence in
democracy that every year UK politicians
tell the public they can reduce
immigration by tens of thousands and
then find they miss their targets by
hundreds of thousands Boris Johnson may
2016. now this was not to say that
Johnson was on anti-immigration leader
or anything of the sort no he was simply
saying that he did not agree with the
uncontrolled arrival of hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of people every
year but at the same time he also said
things like this Boris Johnson says low
immigration could lead to economic
stagnation be that as it may at the time
Johnson was the mayor of London and
although it was already clear that his
goal was to get to 10 Downing Street he
had to wait following the resignation of
David Cameron who had campaigned to
remain in the European Union his foreign
minister Theresa May took over the helm
[Music]
and may failed miserably in managing the
negotiations to complete brexit her
resignation handed the leadership of the
government to Boris Johnson in July of
2019. so one of the first things the new
British prime minister did was to start
working precisely on the migration issue
and so in March 2021 his government
presented a new plan for immigration
policy a plan that ultimately became a
bill presented to the House of Commons
at the end of June 2021 and passed in
April 2022 we will look at that in more
detail in a moment
thank you
and yes for almost a decade now British
politics has been practically obsessed
with this issue however if we take into
account the arrival of foreigners during
the Johnson period things did not change
much except for the fact that
immigration shot up even more for
example we can take a look at what
happened with the refugees as you could
see in 2019 the British authorities
approved 70 more applications and after
the pandemic the numbers grew even more
and this was just one example because
the truth is that work visas also
skyrocketed from the time that Johnson
took office almost 70 percent more were
granted in 2022 than in 2016. the year
of the referendum see for yourself to
the question that begs to be asked is
what on Earth happened wasn't brexit
supposed to be about limiting
immigration wasn't Johnson a strong
advocate of border control has the UK
become an Open Door model well having
asked the questions let's get to the
answers
[Music]
Game Change
the United Kingdom like the rest of
Europe has a massive need for a young
Workforce that's because our population
is getting older and older but also
because companies need very different
profiles from those oriented towards
low-skilled jobs with very little added
value which the British no longer want
to do to those highly specialized
profiles that are essential for the most
cutting-edge Industries for example for
the technology industry or for the very
important British financial industry so
Johnson arrived at 10 Downing Street
with this contradiction on his hands on
the one hand he was supposed to fulfill
the brexit promises and bring forward a
reform that would order and reduce the
arrival of foreigners but on the other
hand it had to be a reform that would
not be a hindrance to the National
economy and the question is what do you
think happened well we've already seen
it the data leaves us in No Doubt
and you know what's strange that all
this didn't particularly erode Johnson's
popularity suddenly what was such an
absolutely crucial issue to the point of
bringing about the exit from the
European Union became well something
less significant in fact according to a
study prepared by The Institute of
politics at King's College London since
brexit the rejection of the British
towards foreign workers has collapsed a
different Trend to what is happening in
countries such as Australia or Canada
don't say it's not paradoxical the
British seem to be becoming much more
open and receptive in the immediate
aftermath of leaving the European Union
despite the fact that the main electoral
motive of the pro-brexit camp was
precisely to shut down and drastically
reduce the influx of foreigners which is
exactly the opposite of what is
happening what's more neither has the
increase in Immigration particularly
eroded to the government nor do the
British seem upset and keep in mind that
the rejection of immigrants has
plummeted among all age groups it
doesn't matter whether we're talking
about generation Zed millennials Baby
Boomers or the pre-war generation in
fact in the latter case rejection has
plummeted by less than half in recent
years to just eight percent so The
Logical question is why probably because
of this
the British economy is not going through
its best time but even so the
unemployment rate is very low and there
are many professions with huge shortages
of workers and this explains why for
instance according to a recent ipsos
survey britons are Keen to see more
doctors nurses and even Farmers coming
to the country in fact less than 20 of
britons now want to see a reduction in
the influx of professionals from
virtually any activity interestingly The
Only Exception is bankers
[Music]
but it is clear that this phobia has
much more to do with banks than Bank
workers and that's not all the same
ipsos survey shows that 46 of britons
rate the impact of immigration
positively compared to 29 who rate it
negatively a negative perception that
curiously has not stopped dropping since
precisely 2016. in other words now that
many more immigrants are arriving the
British are no longer worried of course
the British public is one thing and
politicians are another the current
conservative government is pushing ahead
with the reform of immigration law that
is so controversial that it has even
been brought before the European Court
of human rights do you want to know what
I'm talking about well let's take a look
[Music]
playing with fire
as it stands the British may not care
much about the immigration issue anymore
but at the same time the politicians are
still going strong in April 2022 the
Johnson Administration succeeded in
getting its new immigration plan
approved for example the new law
introduced a two-tier system that
offered refugees at different levels of
protection depending on how they entered
the UK those entering via safe and legal
routes were granted permission to stay
unconditionally but those entering
irregularly could only apply for a
temporary stay of 30 months and not only
that the reform also sought to give the
British Navy control of the territorial
Waters of the English Channel and to be
in charge of controlling immigration via
that route on top of that this other
possibility was included if they go down
that road if they cross the English
Channel illegally in those boats they
risk ending up not in the UK but in
Rwanda Boris Johnson yeah you heard that
correctly to combat illegal immigration
the Johnson government reached an
agreement with Rwanda to receive all
immigrants who were not accepted by the
United Kingdom
thank you
basically the British authorities would
refer to the African country all those
people with rejected applications who
were deemed ineligible or who were
living in the country illegally well the
first flight under this new Mass
deportation plan was scheduled for 14th
of June 2022 but had to be suspended
following an injunction from the
European Court of human rights as the
British idea seemed to clash with
multiple International conventions
what's more there are serious doubts
that it's the best option rwanda's
history of receiving deportees raises
concerns for a potential UK scheme of
about 4 000 people estimated to have
been deported by Israel to Rwanda and
Uganda under a voluntary departure
scheme between 2014 and 2017. almost all
are thought to have left the country
almost immediately without many
attempting to return to Europe via
people smuggling roots for its part
Australia's experience which for years
has done something very similar with
illegal immigrants has also aroused much
criticism and many many doubts Naru
refugees the island where children law
lost the will to live we have started to
see suicidal behavior in children as
young as 8 and 10 years old says Louise
Newman a professor of Psychiatry at the
University of Melbourne Australia who
works with families and children on the
island the fact is that the government
crises of first Boris Johnson and then
Liz truss halted the Rwandan alternative
despite this and despite all the
criticism we can say that Johnson had a
reasonably open-minded position at least
if we compare it with the current
situation because now there's a new
government and guess what Rishi Sue next
team has plunged into a huge
parliamentary battle to push through its
own reform of the same law that was
already amended just over a year ago at
the behest of Boris Johnson's government
and they are from the same party
[Music]
the most curious thing is that despite
the fact that the British rejection of
the arrival of immigrants and refugees
has plummeted Sue next government wants
to tighten Johnson's law for example
that law allowed refugees who entered
the country irregularly to qualify for a
30-month permit to stay now the British
government's objective is to prevent any
person who enters irregularly from
obtaining any permit or residency status
not even Refugee status sunak's idea is
that if you enter the country
irregularly neither you nor your
children will be able to get any kind of
residence permit the spirit is that if
you enter irregularly whatever your
status you will face detention and
deportation the bill will radically
overhaul how we deal with people who
arrive in the UK illegally via safe
countries rendering their Asylum and
human rights claims in respect of their
home country inadmissible and imposing a
duty on the Home Secretary to remove
them Robert genre minister of State for
immigration and keep in mind this
basically means abolishing the concept
of political call Asylum the United
Kingdom would no longer be a possible
destination for people who are forced to
leave their countries as soon as
possible because they are being
persecuted it is true that there is a
lot of fraud but obviously in many
situations if your life or Freedom are
in imminent danger for example because
of political ideas or for defending
democracy you're not going to go through
bureaucratic procedures that could take
years well sunxplan would have none of
that in mind this is one of the main
criticisms of a policy bet that as you
can see is a very strict much more so
than Johnson's gamble but that's not all
right here is where it gets particularly
Raw
[Applause]
now the sunac government has doubled
down and has already made the Rwanda
deal official despite the fact that
according to polls the majority of
britons are against it the objective of
this Arrangement is to create a
mechanism for the relocation of Asylum
Seekers whose claims are not being
considered by the United Kingdom to
Rwanda which will process their claims
and settle or remove as appropriate
individuals after their claim is decided
memorandum of understanding between the
government of Rwanda and the government
of the United Kingdom and the question
is the big question if the British
public apparently don't have so much of
a problem with immigration anymore and
if they are against deporting people to
Rwanda why this political bent basically
because of this six May local elections
2023 labor overtakes conservatives as
largest party of local government the
pandemic Johnson's fall the Liz truss
crisis inflation Rising rates the state
of the economy the conservative party is
facing a tough electoral crisis
[Music]
as you can see in this chart the poles
are clear for the next election in 2025
labor currently seems to be the clear
favorite and the question you may be
asking is what role does immigration
play in all of this basically everything
indicates that the sunak government
wants to turn immigration back into one
of its major workhorses in other words
the government may want to bring this
issue back into the Limelight to show
toughness and force it is something that
worked for the conservatives in the past
and so now they seem to want to try it
again and that is precisely why they are
launching particularly tough messages
and initiatives such as confining
illegal immigrants in a huge boat 7th
August 2023 Britain begins detaining
migrants on Barge firefighters called
death trap or make announcements like
this one I've increased raids by 50 to
clamp down on illegal workers I saw
firsthand the impact this will have in
deterring people from coming here when I
joined immigration Enforcement Officers
last month for what was the biggest ever
single day of raid turning all this into
some kind of show and publicity campaign
doesn't seem like the best way to deal
with this problem of course this is
essentially being done with refugees and
illegal immigrants because when it comes
down to it the UK is likely to continue
issuing as many work permits as it has
been doing so far after all if one thing
is clear it is that the British economy
is going to continue to need a lot of
new labor in other words beyond the
importance of discouraging illegal
immigration or whether or not there is
room for improvement in the British
immigration system there are many
suspicions that the latest legal changes
may be primarily electoral in nature
with all the problems the UK has this
does not seem like a sensible priority
be that as it may at this point it's
your turn what do you think of sunax
political bet do you agree with the
deportations to Rwanda what do you think
of such initiatives as always leave your
impressions in the comments and let's
open a debate now if you found the video
interesting don't forget to like And
subscribe to visualpolitik if you have
not already done so all the best see you
next time
[Music]